mit lehm laufe ich mit und mit wem nicht
an wessen seite möchte ich stehen das
kann jeder von uns in seinem leben
entscheiden für sich er hat das
entschieden er hat diese wahl für sich
getroffen max otte noch cdu-mitglied er
möchte jetzt stehen zwischen alice weidl
und tino copala den beiden fdp chefs im
bundestag hat sich von ihnen für die
bundespräsidentenwahl nominieren lassen
was soll das frage ich ihn jetzt hat
aber
es geht hier nicht um irgendwas nein es
geht um das höchste amt im deutschen
starter das amt des bundespräsidenten
und er tritt dabei nochmal an frank
walter steinmeier und auch er tritt nun
an dominiert von der afg max otte aber
wer ist dieser typ wer ist max otte ein
ökonom ist er ein fondsmanager der mit
diesem bestseller hier bekannt geworden
ist weil er einen finanzcrash prophezeit
hat aber derselbe max otte der hat jahre
später auch für die betrüger von
wirecard geworben und er hat nach dem
brutalen dem rechtsterroristische mord
an walter lübcke kritisiert dass es
angeblich eine hetze gegen die rechte
szene in diesem land gebe und derselbe
max otte hat zwei pässe den deutschen
und den amerikanischen und er ist seit
30 jahren cdu-mitglied und soll jetzt
rausgeworfen werden aus der partei und
bei mir jetzt die cdu legende darf ich
sagen wolfgang bosbach schönen guten tag
herr bosbach an nachweisen warum
schmeißen sie den jetzt raus aus der cdu
den max otte
weil es eine unvereinbarkeit beschluss
gibt zwischen der cdu deutschlands und
der afd hier müssen wir auch eine ganz
ganz klare trennlinie ziehen denn wenn
wir glaubwürdig überzeugen auch
konservative positionen vertreten wollen
dann müssen wir diesen ganz klaren
strich nach rechts außen ziehen damit
auch die gleichung nicht immer stimmt
konservativ gleich rechts gleichen
anziehen jetzt tritt er da an im dienste
der afg was glauben sie was sein motiv
ist sie kennen ihn auch ein bisschen
also warum macht er das mit
gute ich kann mir da auch keinen reim
darauf machen außer er fühlt sich jetzt
wichtig fühlt sich jetzt wahrgenommen
wenn auch von einer anderen politischen
partei nicht von seiner partei der cdu
jetzt ist er wieder eine bedeutende
persönlichkeit wenn ich selber
vorgeschlagen worden wäre für mich wäre
das kein kompliment bei dem vorschlag
der afg für mich persönlich wäre es eher
eine beleidigung ich hoffe immer noch er
kommt zu dem ergebnis nein ja wenn wir
ihm ins gesicht sagen die max otte wenn
sie mir jetzt begegnet werden liebe otto
sie müssen sich entscheiden zwischen an
der mitgliedschaft in der cdu und einer
reise auf dem dicke der asd beides
gleichzeitig geht nicht und wenn er
meint es ginge doch dann muss ihm die
cdu nicht rauswerfen weil er sich dann
selber aus der cdu verabschiedet hat
danke herzlich für das gespräch wolfgang
bosbach
ich danke ihm
bewusst über die merkel politik frust
über die cdu gleichzeitig die lust am
tabu brechen sich selbst zu profilieren
aber sich dafür in den dienst der afg zu
stellen ist es ihnen das wert der orte
das frage ich ihn jetzt
begrüße ich bei bild max auch tageweise
im leben kann man sich entscheiden
welcher seite man stehen möchte sie
haben sich jetzt entschieden an der
seite von alice seite zu stehen und von
tino kubala film sich da wohl in der
mitte der beiden ich stehe nicht in der
seite an der seite der beiden sondern
ich kann auch ihre für ein amt was über
den beiden steht aber schauen sie hinter
mir sie stehen an der seite der ball ja
das war jetzt bei der erklärung aber das
amt steht natürlich über den beiden wenn
ich so sagen darf sie haben das amberger
an ihr aber ich strebe eine amt an was
darüber steht was auch über den parteien
stehen sollte von daher habe ich diese
ankündigung an der seite der beiden
gemacht und es wird keine weiteren
interviews geben und ich kandidiere für
ein amt was über den parteien sie lassen
sich von den beiden nominieren und
distanzieren sich jetzt von den beiden
nein nein ich distanziere mich nicht
sondern ich sage ich habe aus eigenem
antrieb dieses amt strebe ich an und das
amt steht über der parteipolitik ist ist
mein anliegen auf verschiedene dinge im
land hinzuweisen zum beispiel die
ausgrenzung der ungeimpften zum beispiel
die
sich die vermögens- schwere die auf
klafft aber sie haben eben diesen hebel
benutzt den hebel afd den hebel alice
weidl und den hebel kino kuba und den
hebel von vielen mehr denn da fehlen ja
noch einige auf dem foto die man
hinzufügen könnte also zum beispiel
ihnen hier den kennen sie wahrscheinlich
auch den fdp bundestagsabgeordneten
münzenmaier der ein jahr ein
strafverfahren gegen sich laufen ja hat
solche warum halten wir auch über young
music können wir auch über die von der
linkspartei sprechen jetzt kommt na ja
da haben sie ja nicht nominiert wir
müssen auch ein ja aber ihnen sprechen
ja waren hingegen gerade die straße
einfahren neuer in allen dingen müsse
über kein ich spreche über kann heute
aber dass ich mich nicht sie sind der
kandidaten die sat 1 ja isch kandidiere
für das amt des bundespräsidenten es
gibt ein wahlprozess ich bin der
kandidat in einem geheimen wahlverfahren
auch alle anderen auch von denen und die
sitzen in der bundesversammlung also
hier und heute wird auch in der
bundesversammlung 6 ist eine geheime
wahl sind sein kann ihr habe ich möchte
nicht über die drei sprechen mache ich
nicht aber sie können sich ja nicht in
der afg nur die aussuchen die
möglicherweise gerade rechts und sie
haben sich von den allen ich suche mir
keinen aus die leute suchen mich aus als
und wählen mich und zwar
parteiübergreifend unter umständen
vielleicht kommen ja auch stimmen aus
anderen parteien es ist eine
demokratische wahl ich möchte mich über
diese leute nicht unterhalten genauso
wie wir uns nicht über die linksextremen
unterhalten müssen die hellenen die
haben über die die immer ganz doch die
anrede reichlich mit darum müssen wir
ganz viel regen aber sie haben sich ja
von denen wir haben darstellen lassen
das sind die die sie unterstützen ja
aber ich spreche nicht darüber ich
spreche über das amt die spricht über
meine anliegen ist eine geheime wahl in
einer geheimen wahl ist es zunächst
einmal egal von wem man gewählt würde
ich mache nicht den kemmerich sie machen
genau den kämmerern auch nicht genau von
einem menschen ja unterstützen und hat
den handschlag thomas kämmer lasse mich
in einem demokratischen prozess
unterstützen aber ich werde nicht
zurückweichen
sie haben in dieser woche gesagt in
diesen zeiten das waren mit blick auf
stefan hilse den
fdp-bundestagsabgeordneten der jetzt
gerade in strafverfahren gegen sich hat
weil der widerstand gegen die polizei
geleistet hat haben sie gesagt das sei
in diesen zeiten auch zu verstehen das
sei in diesen zeiten haben sie gesagt in
ordnung widerstand gegen die polizei zu
leisten ich find das spektakulär auch
ein stückweit absurd für jemanden der
staatsoberhaupt werden möchte dass der
salon in diese zeit in roßdorf ich
zitiere gustav heinemann der bürger das
recht und die pflicht die politik darauf
hinzuweisen wenn sie das recht bricht
und der bürger hat das recht zum
widerstand ich mir nehme mein ganz
großes beispiel am großen
bundespräsidenten gustav heinemann der
das wahrscheinlich genauso gesehen die
nehmen sie für sich den nehme ich für
mich in anspruch in anspruch weil der
kollege auf der kollege von ihnen auf na
ist kein kollege dass ich verbitte mehr
kollege es ist ein politiker ist es kein
kollege meine parteifreunde ist eine cdu
die sind im moment nicht so begeistert
über mich das ist kein kollege ich
verbitte mir diesen ausdruck es gab
besonderen vorfall jetzt wieder in
sachsen vor dem haus von petra köpping
sachsens gesundheitsministerin zum
wiederholten male jetzt diesmal und
bands afd landtagsabgeordnete ich dachte
eigentlich sie kommen jetzt her und
sagen mensch unter dem geschehen dort
was ja nochmal was besonderes ist diese
frau ist unter druck gesetzt nicht
ausstehen kenntnissen ich von diesen
männern hand und ich kenne den vorfall
ich das ja gut aber ich kann nicht alle
vorfälle kennen ich habe keinen großen
stab von demel tragen dass ich habe auch
keinen großen spaß gemacht das ist aber
heute als zu leben jemand unter druck
gesetzt wird missbillige ich dass das
sind allerdings noch mal herr ortet das
sind die menschen die sie mit normalen
dekra sie sind hoffen sie sind die
hoffnung der menschen die die sächsische
gesundheitsministerin direkt vor dem
haus und deren familien unter druck
stehen die hoffnung der menschen die
sich nicht impfen lassen wollen die sich
nicht diskriminieren lassen wollen ich
bin die hoffnung der abgestiegene
menschen der mittelschicht und die der
geringverdiener marginalisierten ich
habe als junger mensch johnny cash war
mein erster großer held man musikalisch
erhält da hat sich auch für die
unterprivilegierten eingesetzt und das
habe ich mein ganzes leben lang und ich
bin die hoffnung ja für die menschen die
ihre grundrechte eingeschränkt zwischen
johnny cash und alice weidl und johnny
cash und alexander gauland ist eine
weitere rains ich bin auch nicht die
hoffnung für alexander gauland für alle
zweifel die haben ihr leben im griff ich
kandidiere für ein amt wo ich
hoffnungsträger für andere menschen bin
ich habe von diesem und dieser
kandidatur persönlich nur nachteile nur
nachteile sie sind plötzlich wieder in
der öffentlichkeit sie sind plötzlich
wieder gefragt wie aber durch das
spricht über sie habe ich bin hatte ich
bin ich bin froh manager also darum geht
es ja nicht weil ich
das ist ja keine öffentlichkeit die
irgendetwas in gewisser weise meinem mir
bringt im gegenteil sie schadet mehr sie
schadet mir geschäftlich finanzielle ich
mache das aus überzeugung noch mal auf
die vorfälle auf die ganzen
genannten personen zu spüren wir jetzt
sagen und sie sind wir unangenehmen ja
also heute fällt schon mal den den platz
vier und damit den wollen sie nichts zu
tun haben müssen einig und rückt ich
möchte nicht nein das möchte ich nicht
möchte nicht dass es so befremdlich dass
die hier stehen wie gesagt ist eine
wichtige sache nicht einmal eine
einmalige noch gesagt gefragt ist das
eine frame doch wir können uns dann über
beide seiten und da halten wir können zu
über linke gewalt wenn es über
linksextremismus in der bundesliga oder
dann richten wir ganz viel da haben wir
glaube ich gar kein nachholbedarf das
problem ist dass sie sich von denen
unterstützen lassen und das soll durch
besonderes und problems sind und
menschen durch design problem dominiert
haben deswegen werden sie es den ganzen
bundespräsidentenwahlkampf aushalten
muss ich aushalten aber ich halte es
nicht aus wenn man mir das so davor
stellt weil über mich sprechen haben sie
über die drei haben sie beseitigt der
wird allerdings wie gesagt auch in der
bundesversammlung dann sitzen also sie
nehmen jetzt nicht die gelegenheit war
gerade nachdem ich auch von den
vorfällen dort in sachsen ihnen erzählt
hat von denen sie jetzt noch nichts
wussten dass sie sagen mensch angesichts
dessen dass kann ich glaube ich mit
meinem gewissen nicht vereinbaren ich
hingegen drei sätzen zum im gegenteil
sowie die zustände im land sind sowie
die polarisierung ist sowie die hetzjagd
sind sowie die fehlende diskurs kultur
ist ist es mir eine gewissensfrage
dieses zu machen und es ist eine
nominierung das amt steht über den
parteien es ist denn mit meinem gewissen
mein gewissen verpflichtet mich dazu
ließen das heißt egal was jetzt auch
noch im zuge ihrer kandidatur passiert
in den reihen der ard in reihen der
fraktionen die sie nominiert hat völlig
egal was die sich leisten was passiert
in dieser zeit sie werden daran nicht
rütteln es gibt nicht den moment wo sie
sagen würden das ist jetzt echt zuviel
dort sich zu den moment würde es geben
das kann ich nur vorstelle das ist das
kann ich vorher nicht den kann ich vor
nicht sehen ließ sich eine situation die
sie entwickelt aber da muss schon sehr
viel passieren es ist ja schon sehr viel
prämisse sein anders der moment kann es
geben aber ich halte natürlich an der
kandidatur fest trotz all dieser
verhören dass es kein verhör hatte das
ist ein interview trotzdem noch mal
nachgefragt weil mich diese schwelle
einfach interessant wann ist für sie der
punkt sie haben ja gesagt den gibt es wo
sie sagen jetzt ist genug jetzt mehr
geht nicht für mich war der punkt schon
gar nicht gekommen da sag ich kann das
ja ist genügend lanciert in reihen der
ard mit denen kann man nicht gemeinsame
sache machen aus meiner sicht sie
definieren das für sich anders aber was
ist der punkt ich definiere es anderes
kann ich ihnen jetzt noch nicht sagen
diesem punkt gibt es aber die situation
entwickelt sich weiter ist jetzt stehe
ich dazu es ist ein demokratischer
prozess ich habe meine anliegen das amt
steht über den parteien und so möchte
ich so behandelt wissen sie haben jetzt
immer wieder die rechte der ungeimpften
angesprochen die sich wie sie sagen
ausgegrenzt fühlen in diesem land wir
haben oft darüber
berichtet hatte werden sie eigentlich im
bundestag im parlament bei der
bundesversammlung auch oben auf der
tribüne platz nehmen ja weil sie nicht
geimpfte ich bin nicht geimpft ich bin
gelesen ich hatte cupid in alaska das
war ziemlich hässlich eine woche und
dann habe ich zwei monate nach
nachwirkungen gehabt aber ich war
gelesen bin es jetzt nach neuem recht
nicht nur das ist ja auch eine paradoxie
und dann muss man weitersehen also ich
bin dabei genießen danke für das
gespräch bei bild danke
ein mann also der sich ganz bewusst auch
wählen lassen will auch von antisemiten
auch von verurteilten straftätern der es
auch in ordnung findet in diesen zeiten
wir hier gerade noch mal im studio
gesagt hat widerstand gegen die polizei
zu leisten der will staatsoberhaupt
werden der tritt an zur
bundespräsidentenwahl gegen einen der
schwächsten bundespräsidenten die wir
wohl je hatten aber er wird verlieren
deutlich